all right phillip and welcome back
thank you so we were just chatting
before the camera started rolling about
how
honesty is very freeing yes it is and
you uh
you had an old friend of yours contact
you recently and uh from college um up
through a facebook that messenger
i saw your video saw the video probably
the first one uh the first one
and he said something along the lines of
i respect you for
putting yourself out there like that and
i thought that that was nothing i was
just telling
myself my story but yeah people
hide too often
they prefer a delusion
rather than reality and that's really
shocking coming
from california where we live where
people will create themselves be
anything that they want in their own
image
and we have people like that i mean
those are the ones that move here and
then yeah have that
heirs of whatever it is and nastiness on
them
no i can see why people hate celebrities
because the people that try to be the
celebrities
and ones that are above themselves and
whatnot they're the ones that
because of them the kardashians exist
and you know the
reality programming [ __ ] that no i
don't care for that
i want genuine well i know that my
audience
responds very positively to someone who
really just lays it all out
as pi as patrick and norman and yourself
and and many others have done
and when they're when they're more
guarded they yeah
it shows i'm pretty sure i mean i've not
watched many of your other videos a
couple of them here and there
and i found myself most engrossed by the
ones that
spoke in a way that's genuinely real
about themselves and they laid
ownership of it the ones that
handed hard and got a little silly
yeah it showed that it showed up and
i can't imagine what it would be like
interviewing them i mean i
i sympathize with you for the bad ones
because that's just a bit too
much you know yeah i mean it's still a
rarity to have someone who really just
makes themselves very vulnerable and
talks about everything and anything
man i do you sure did well thank you
those exploits go on they've gone on
your most of your life
um the sexual stuff well
whenever i initiated sex that was when i
was 14.
so many times men had been on my own
terms
so to speak i did not
go into anything blindly
i said in the uh when i lost my
virginity i was writing to guys
at personal ads saying look i'm 14.
that's illegal
i know this but can you help me out
because i was upfront genuine sincere
it resulted in positive feedback from
a couple different guys
and i've always found that to be the
ways that
if i want something be upfront be
genuine be direct
and so i've done that all the time i'm a
lot more confident
sexually than i am about other things
um probably because i have that
mask or that that
a goal and because i have that goal
i got a laser-focused mind and how to
accomplish it
there's always one area in our lives
where we excel and we don't have any
blocks
i find yeah but then there are other
ones where we're just crippled that's so
unfortunate no so unfortunate because i
mean i would rather have it be about
something that
would apply better to a financial
benefit that would be nice no but if you
can apply the principles that
yeah you use in the areas where you're
successful yeah
to the ones where you're you have blocks
yeah and sometimes you can you can plow
through them
yeah i like that
um and that's where
i'm still learning different things
about myself like that how to
best utilize my resources not my
my strengths in ways that would be
advantageous
um all too often i find myself
becoming
caught up in other people's [ __ ]
and that just leads to
a lack of focus and that's where the
aloof or um
scatter brain you know just the part
that's not me
will show up when that happens there's a
lot of idiots out there
and my my flaw is
i'm sure i say this correctly my flaw is
that
i
i'm sorry oh a bit overwhelmed
my flaw is that i
associate with people
um that are clearly inferior
to me i don't want to say it like that
but
i dump myself down
and that's only because i'm at a whole
another level
up there and
i don't think there's many out there
that can
understand or
be able to come have a conversation on a
heightened level
on a regular basis i have one person in
my life that's like that
um 60 year old dude but um
aside from that i don't have anyone of
that challenges me
up here and i love that i love my
brain stimulated with you know just
thoughts and topics and conversations
all too often no it's about like
um listening to uh drake
or you know something stupid nonsense
claptrap
and i don't like that in my life i like
purpose you do you find your sexual
sexual inclination and the friends the
the
acquaintances that you have because of
that
makes your circle of friends what it is
um
i separate my
sexual self from everything else
itself uh yeah as a result um
the sexual self is able to
um interact with
uh type people
i can't find the right word because
that's that's how they beat me down
sometimes
so your standards are much lower
sexually than they are
[Music]
for stimulation mental stimulation
i do not want that to interfere with
sexual
stimulation um
i like those parts separated um
and not everything is always about sex i
mean yes
i i'm rather much a warm dog but
i think all guys are on some capacity
um i'm sure there's different ways that
it's handled
but you know if you were to ask an
average guy
um how often they think of sex know i
don't really maybe look at chicks
you know asses or tits or something like
that
i'm sure that the response is going to
be more often than normal
that's so they'll say um and so yeah
the same thing applies to me you know
just my parts are different than
the ones that they like um
what goals do you have in your life
damn damn um
i that's why i moved to california
10 years ago well in 2012. so
nine years ago this fall this december
um to find what my purpose is
when i was in the nursing home back in
2010
for three months and i was learning
everything over again
like learning how to walk and how to
write my name and stuff like that
um because these are things i could not
do it was shocking
how i had to relearn everything
basically and
when i did i said what is my purpose why
am i alive
what what convinced god or whomever
to not strike me you know take me away
already with all the bad things that
have happened to me
what's why am i here and that's what i
have been still trying to find for the
last decade and there you go there you
go
there you go that's why i hate these
interview things because you're making
me
realize things about myself thanks a
hell of a lot
um just simply enough
i
have to accept that
god i'm sorry i'm just
i need that
mental challenge that helps to
focus reinvigorate me you know
that's what that is i need to have that
in my life on a regular basis and i
don't have that
and therefore i'm spinning my wheels you
get lost
huh you get lost yeah because
there's no focus and that's exactly it
so again shame on you for making me
realize things about myself the same
thing creatively if i'm not working on
something
a creative project yeah i drift and i
end up doing things i would never ever
do
um what's your sign
aquarius okay cool cool
um
don't you hate it i'm sorry not to
change subjects
when people say that aquarius is a water
sign because it means accurate
no it's not i don't buy any of that
stuff exactly okay yeah you said that
before i forgot i was born in february
yeah very first so it's like that's just
i was born in february it was cold yeah
my mom had to
you know go to the hospital when it was
cold that's all it means it just means
that you had the shortest month
so if you were to celebrate but there
are psychological
theories the enneagram is one of them
that's really great that i find
breaks down everyone into nine different
types what do you call it
the enneagram e-n-n-e-a-g-r-a-m
and it okay um there's many books on it
okay the best books are written the
author is
i think is richard rizzo riso okay um
and it breaks down everyone in terms of
their
their the fears that drive them and
their their
their their aim in life their goals okay
and for some
it's security and depending on whether
we're acting out of fear or out of love
we'll
we'll either destroy our own security or
we'll
attain it somehow yeah if we're healthy
we achieve our goals and if we don't we
self-destruct
huh and it's like you uh you create what
you defend against
yeah and with the enneagram each of the
nine types
some of us are focused on always being
right others are focused on trying to
attain love
others want to be admired some are
focused on being unique
for others it's being certain of their
thoughts
others are focused on having security
and some of us want to be acquisitive
when i have fun or always
seeking a good time and others want to
be dominant
over others and some of us want to be at
peace and depending on how you go about
attaining these things whether you do it
out of love or out of fear
will decide whether you you
self-destruct or whether you find what
you're what you're looking for
yeah okay i can see that that's very
important
that i apply to every single person i
talk to and meet and everything it's
it's like you you find out what drives
them you find out what they're all about
yeah you find out what they're going to
do and why they do it
not that i thought i sit around
analyzing everyone but not but but but
it does
i applied to myself more than anyone and
it it really
in my kids or whatever it really shows
what why they're doing what they're
doing
what their purpose behind it is
their motivation their motivation where
they're going with and if you're doing
it in a healthy way that's great and if
they're not they're going to end up
you know exactly how they're going to
solve this drug i can read them like a
book now the self-destruct button you
can see it yeah
yeah oh no i see it down here on skid
row i see it everywhere oh i'm sure
it's it's it's written on their forehead
yeah
um yeah there's a lot of
incomplete thoughts you know just in
terms of yeah
and i would guess you're an enneagram
five oh okay
i'll have to look at it yes um
but um there was something i'll get to
it in a second because i had it
and i'm a three and a four right there
you're right three row four okay three
mostly okay well guess what
i'm a five you are that's not just one
there's like two numbers no no no none
already better than anyone else
there's no better or worse it's just
exactly just i'm changed is this the
category
it could be anything so for you
knowledge and certainty would be your
drives
knowledge um and having answers to
things
yeah you'd have a hard time acting until
you had all the answers and you're never
going to have all the answers in life
you never will you're going to have to
act out of a situation where you don't
know it all
and that takes courage i hate
not being accurate and so therefore i
over analyze and make sure that i got
all
my eyes crossed and t's dotted and
i guess you don't got t's or cross eyes
but you got the idea yeah
um i
spend so much time therefore whenever i
speak i'm speaking from a point of truth
and therefore wow this is something i
don't think i discussed
with you directly but with someone else
where
when i was a customer service rep at
blue cross and detroit
you know 10 years ago it's one oh god a
long time ago 20 years ago
um i was so adamant
that i was not going to get less than
100 quality scores that
whenever i got a citation saying oh well
you did this wrong
i would fight them the quality
department
and i would have things overturned
because i was correct
or you know i had my truth that
explained to things
and it got so bad that
because of the usage of an ampersand in
a letter that i
sent out but because i believe that the
ampersand was correct
and used in the right way as it is per
the apa style guidelines and whatnot
but so in order to make them happy
i had to re-change the whole wording of
the paragraph
that's fine i'll do it to placate them
but it frustrated me to think that i was
not
accurate with how i presented myself
and that made me there was a drive right
there how to
get that repealed all right you know the
the the demerit you know wiped off
because i'll be damned if i'm gonna be
told i'm not perfect
i mean i try to be and that's the thing
you can't
be perfect all the time
but then what's the purpose of
everything being accurate
why father
what things when everyone goes at it
half fast
does that make sense because if
you're not putting full effort into
things
why why
there should be but you'll never have
complete certainty you'll never have
you'll never be
100 right you'll never be admired by
everyone all the time you'll never
have love exactly the way you want it
you'll never have
power ultimately yeah you'll never have
security power
uh all the things that we
try to attain right on your terms
completely you're gonna
have to make compromises and work with
that and just
keep going with without everything you
want
yeah i'm not big on compromise but it's
almost like you're compromising
like in this case your
your your desire to be right or to know
it all or to be
to not be a
idiot that speaks on [ __ ]
coming from a spot that
there's no truth to what they say
i pride myself on being sincere
or accurate pardon me sorry
but
that's where i fail a lot just in terms
of
myself and i beat myself up way too much
i think we all do yeah
i just sorry
but you hear that out there i'm trying
to ignore but
i just i'm
i get thrown around a lot up here
because of positions that i put myself
in
i think that's something we've discussed
before that sounds familiar
i wish i did not do that to myself
but i have
and that's where
i have to do better for myself and
figure out what the hell my purpose is
in life
but what what regrets do you have
let's see
i regret not
playing the corporate game a little bit
smarter
and then that yes man that would have
got me the job at six figures a year
that i was trying to get
at my job how to play that game
right that's not me as a person
that's why i love being in union i could
just be crass in myself
and they would stand up for me
but in order to be a success
at certain things you have to compromise
you know certain things and
i don't know because if i did do that
then i would feel ugly on the inside and
therefore
so my regrets just come from the fact
that
there's a lot of
pie in the sky fantastical things
that the pisces can do i mean just in
terms of creating a perfect
fantasy land in their head but
i do not
actively seek it to achieve it
yeah i like that
sorry but that basically is it
i
oh god sorry just i
get too frustrated with myself
i'm sorry i just sound like a stupid
person just
repeating things and no i think we all
do this
it's important stuff to think about yeah
you make me think too much
but it's a good thing i think all the
time it challenges me and that's what i
like like i said
just to have that
focus on myself and i don't do that
that's what i like about interviews with
you is that
for the rest of that day i have a
clearer head
you know a sharper mind and
from here now i'll be able to hopefully
do that again today
and then speak
on things to certain people
conversations that are going to be
uncomfortable but are definitely going
to be required
i need to stop
um delaying or
being fearful of hurting people's
feelings
because certain things have to be said
and done
and that's what interviews with you help
me do better for myself
i'm not flawless with it but i mean i'm
on a good path right now and i like that
sorry but yeah i like that
it's interesting to see how interviewees
inter um behave when they're in here
with me
and then how they behave outside a lot
of my viewers don't see that
yeah so many people are different
animals out there
than they are when they're in you see a
mask out there like they're putting in
here they put on their their most
presentable face yeah
they're they're thoughtful they're
respectable they're
yeah they're re they're almost like
refined
and when you see that when you see them
out there they're they're
they're doing the most unthinkable
things to other people or themselves
yeah and it's like that's they didn't
show any of that
when they were in here and it's it's you
know i don't want to exploit these
people and just
make them look like wild animals but
sometimes they do behave like wild
animals out there
when you are aware of that
do you sometimes
lead the conversation to have them catch
themselves
no no i don't play games like that i
just
i just ask the questions i do and give
them their answers and sometimes their
answers are
honest and they make themselves
vulnerable sometimes they're lying and
that's where you
get more truth i find by listening to
their lies because whatever someone's
lying about is something they're really
defending and trying to hide
yeah for the best example is like a
middle-aged prostitute who tells me
tells me she's 24.
why would she lie about her age like so
extremely it's because she's scared
shitless of losing the one thing she
knows how to survive with
which is her attractiveness her sex
appeal
so she can make money to support her
drug habit or her
support herself okay so when she says
she's 24
yeah we can all call her out on the fact
that she's lying about her age but if
we're really
insightful we'll see that she's really
just very insecure about being 48
yeah or 43 or whatever she is
and that fear tells you what she's
really
what's going on in her life okay that's
how i operate
that's why i think when i when i do talk
so i'm not i'm not really looking to
expose that
right or exploit what these people are
all about
because they're putting on their best
face when they're in here and
you have to consider in every single one
of these stories
including yours that your parents or
your siblings or your
significant other would have a different
story to tell about
whatever you're talking about yeah i
mean and including me everybody would
tell it a certain way my sister would be
like no that's that's not her or my
my ex-girlfriends or whatever and this
is what a topic i talked about with a
friend of mine that
we don't have the benefit of seeing
ourselves
the way that others see us so we have
our own
image of how i present myself yeah and i
think i'm just fine most of the time but
no i can see through an outside set of
eyes now
when i talk to them like how i can come
off
sometimes and it is not the
prim and proper respectful person always
i know right
but but i just don't
have
yeah and that's where we all
fail because we have a false image
of ourselves and once you
tone yourself down you can see your true
self
i think that makes sense
just that if you not
if you don't let
false fantasies
about yourself rule your
life you're allowed to be
sincere and therefore that's where the
truth comes in and that's where
that sincerity will show and that's why
i like that about myself
there's a lot of things about you to
like everyone on the street likes you
everyone that knows you
they say nice things about you behind
your back
yeah more than anyone else i've
interviewed wow i mean there's there's a
few people that have those
that going on yeah but you're definitely
one of them well thank you like everyone
that knows you goes like
philip's such a great guy yeah
i know who you know so i mean in terms
of like you know our common
bread of people and yeah those are good
people so i'm i
have respect for them
that's why
i am unafraid of
anything life has to offer or throw at
me because i know how to roll with
punches
and let
that genuine heart or sincerity thing
yeah sure my comes off like babe the pig
you know just that sincere heart will
win the day
ultimately it takes courage to do that
really i have been told that like my
friend that said
i put myself out there on the first
video
hey i was just talking about myself and
[ __ ] but
yeah people don't do that sorry i'm just
like they really don't that's why
when someone like patrick or norman or
yourself
uh really give you a window into
how they're operating what they're
thinking what they're doing
it can be very transformative for them
and it really
resonates with with my audience i think
with anyone because it's
it's what we're all going through yeah
but most of us hide it most of us
you know keep it and that's unfortunate
um out there in
you know youtube land just be genuine
with yourself
and when you're genuine with yourself it
allows you to be free with others
and that's where just putting
nonsense [ __ ] not
overwhelm you or uh
be your barometer of what is acceptable
just be content with yourself
and yeah i think others will
love and respect you more for it yeah
you're afraid
of the opposite happening but the result
proven time and time again here with you
look at the comments on some of those
type of videos yeah the response is
incredibly over you know positive i like
that
there is a very good quality
of audience that you have yeah i don't
know that's the best
way it was worded but yeah you just said
they're more compassionate more
empathetic more
more evolved yeah more evolved
definitely
and so i'm proud of that yeah
it all just comes from you as a person
and that's the reason why you're able to
get that out of your subjects
and present that to the public at large
in a way that's not judging
yeah i mean i i think what i'm trying to
do with this project is
to help us understand each other better
and to be kinder and more compassionate
with less judgment and hatred
i believe the first and most important
step in all of this is to be honest with
ourselves
yeah as you've been my evolved audience
gives me hope for our future
including you know you're you're
evolving you're one of those involved
people that i think can lead the way
into a happier healthier
society wow that's very interesting
that okay that's a nice compliment from
you
well thank you um
yeah i it's hard
for me not to be me does that make sense
that's a great one well thank you um
i can't
have that false
you know like i'm a doctor of a
philosophy and no no no husband
i'm running to someone that is a
philosophy major and then like they'll
ask me something about you know kant and
um
other things like that and then i'll be
like oh i don't know and that's where
then
that being exposed as a fraud
pops up and that's always a fear of mine
so therefore yeah i don't
grant you some certain things
because no that's too much effort
to have a role that you're creating for
yourself you know
what would i spend most of my 20s and
30s
struggling with like i've always been
really really driven and focused and
almost obsessive about whatever i was
into
which was usually a creative project it
was it's always always a creative
project yeah and
in my 20s like you know i was seeing a
therapist and the therapist would say
well you need you need to like you know
relax and not be so this way not be so
that way
i was in my 30s i think and uh i finally
at one point just said
let me experiment with doing the
opposite of what i'm trying to fix
okay let me just give myself even more
to what i'm
into where where it where
where it affects my quality of life even
i was willing to
do a little experiment and when it when
i really just dedicated myself
absolutely 100 to whatever i was into
yeah
and didn't and just threw everything
aside
i was happier than ever yeah and i just
ever since then i just said that's
that's
what i need to that's how i need to live
yeah i like that 100
just throw everything out and and it'll
all come back yeah
the relationships the the the financial
uh stability the the happiness that
it'll it'll all
fall into place beautifully yeah if you
take care of
if you're not fighting against who you
actually are which is what you just said
you know just being happy with who who
you are and you have to figure out who
you are but
it's hard to do that when you're young
yeah the gray hair
your gray beard is what it comes along
with that distinguished
i don't like it i was gonna shave before
i got here but i forgot to do that
earlier today so
damn it well i think you're fascinating
well thank you um i'm something
that's what i say about myself i'm just
you know when i whenever i start into a
relationship with somebody i have to
give them all this like these warning
this little warning talk like i'm i'm
really wound up and i
really work like obsessively and and i
said this to my wife when i get uh
proposed to her
many years ago my ex-wife um and i said
i said look i'm gonna ask you to marry
you but but
but before you say yes you have to
understand i work like a maniac
i'm obsessive about it
and if that's going to be a problem you
shouldn't say yes
right um but i'm also i'm also really
fun too
you know what when i when i put down my
whatever
my project yeah i i'm not like this the
you yourself i'm sure is a very um
chill uh um fun to hang out with type
every every girl i've ever had in my
life has always said man you
i treated them better than any guy that
ever been treated okay i know how to
have a good time
but when i'm not doing that i'm working
like a maniac
and i'm happier and because i'm happier
from that then that that gives me the
ability to have more energy for the
relationship
i like that because i'm happy otherwise
it's how to make yourself happy
how to be a perpetual happy machine yeah
that's what we all want yeah and that
takes that takes
a little bit of introspection and
courage yeah
um
yeah i might be sitting back watching
this you know whenever you post it next
week or whenever
and that damn thing that's in the back
of the mind that i've been trying to say
that i almost was able to say two
minutes five minutes ago
but i mean i was too busy involved with
you in conversation that i could not
get back to that in my head and i
apologize that um
yeah there was something
huh we'll save it for next time there
you go
put it in like on there dot dot dot to
be continued
you're always interesting phone well
thank you love to have you back many
times
sounds good to me excellent have a great
day
yep likewise